rouge flamboyant
écrit par madre
illustration de
histoire là la passer dans le temps
longtemps
dans tout ça toute pied de flamboyante
et il donne fleuve Jaune
elles peuvent madame y rester côté un
carreau de bois d'un petit Guigui
le mur échappé par bout
si Madame la l'était plus que misère
pour toute bien toute fortune elle
n'avait un petit fille qui appelait
Léonie
Léonie faisait tout pour faire plaisir à
ce moment en plus de ça elle était jolie
pareil la lune sous-autier éclaté comme
étoiles son cheveux qui brille en soleil
la pluie tombée par même la tête est sec
en Gratton
rien y pousser plus
les deux trois animaux maigres en lames
couteau définit vanner
Léonie avec son maman
n'avait dans l'habitation souvent des
fois on avait point rien pour mettre
dans la marmite
un jour
pour chèvre la dèche une grosse fièvre
la batte le moment à terre elle était
obligée prendre le lit
comment il se débrouillé là aux enfants
que ça ni ça a fait pour son d'analyser
Léonie l'avait beau tourner tas d'idées
dans sa tête
elle y trouvait pas rien que n'aurait pu
arranger cette situation
et puis tout d'un coup le moment la
soutenue que dans le fond animal elle
avait ramassé cadeau qu'elle avait gagné
et que sa grand-mère
c'était un trou sa table tout en
broderie de silaos être ou ceux comme ça
il veut de l'eau
aux enfants
les cieux la vieille madame Noël d'art
va donne à nous un bonne monnaie pour
trop cela il vous rachète deux trois
pinte maïs et qu'un pizza haricot
un que la morue aussi enfin waouh
laisse des petits Katsu pour prendre une
bouteille l'élixia parigoric
poussin à moi sinon comme moi là il
tarde pas pour les côtés
mais le tracas c'était que madame noëlda
est resté Saint-Pierre
le chemin n'est pas facile du tout pour
aller là-bas
en premier n'avait le grand carreau de
bois pour traverser
dessous il faisait quasiment noir après
ça tu es obligé de couper une ravine
glissant savonnette
après il fallait monter un python à
couverts
imaginez toute qualité dont j'étais
rescabarit ils sont petits-enfants le
coeur moment il y a Marie c'est là
écoulé tout seul
pour apprendre notre médicament et ma
faire cuire un tissus pour remonter à
eau
la
mi le trousseau est précautions
elle a partie
seulement
consolait il a commencé
la maman là on garde par la fenêtre la
source sulfate
alors
par haine pas deux elle attrape sa
capeline pour boire un peu son front que
tu brûle et que la fièvre et elle
appartient
tellement qu'elle a oublié sa faiblesse
sa maladie
comme si elle avait
gain la zèle
vu que la part il m'a le sentiment
elle courait il courait il criait et
crier Léonie mon petit gâté où ça il est
elle a traversé le carreau de bois la
ravine la menthe sulpiton pas tout
saxonctifie nourrit du passé
ces gens métros ok les roches les épines
et graffiné à elle
mais elle y sont pas la douleur
en plus fainois il commençait tomber
quand même ça elle y arrêtait pas de
courir
elle y arrêtait pas crier mon enfant mon
petit Baba en sucre que c'est la passe
dans ma tête pour moi laisse à ou partir
tout seul donc grand chemin c'est là
qu'un petit rayon la lune n'a éclaire à
elle
en même temps en lien là bas sur la tête
le piton elle a entendu un petit voix
faible
viens vite moi il est là
sur le retour la petite fille la gagne
un coup de coin elle a glissé sur le
front le piton heureusement Chico la
barrel là empêche à elle chape dans le
fond
la maman l'a donné la main la elle en
l'air
les joues et le front la maman en terre
rouge en braise elle a cerveau son
enfant dans ses bras après ça toute la
pris une grande respiration
lassise sous un pied de flamboyant pour
apprendre un petit guide la force
sa tessitant fatigué que de la Guinée
grand matin l'heure vous êtes Larousse
de Dieu tout autour n'avait un tapis de
pétales rouge
le moment n'avait plus rien qui faisait
mal la fièvre des fine vol loin le feu
qu'il était sur ses joues sur son front
l'avait fané
les branches le flamboyant
l'été
tout rouge
à partir du jour là
la misère la pizza
les pieds flamboyants aux alentours
la couvert à Fleurus
Paris
à mesure un après l'autre dans notre
petit pays tout le peu de pied de
flamboyant la Guy fleur rouge
Gomez là il peut trouver par-ci par là
un de flamboyants jeunes mais ça ira